si j'en suis le cadet de beaucoup de
gens qui est attendu à part il faudra
recommencer
vous allez voir je suis le roi de la
comptine bon si on met 3 on casse des
assiettes
mais ces mêmes parents les cisco vous
moquez de moi mais tu as tout oublié je
suis une comptine il faut des rimes
je suis à je mange du pain si on est
deux ou quatre saisons qui ont des bons
joueurs
vous avez l'air de bien vous amuser
aujourd'hui or c'est quasi milk a
toujours des problèmes de rim
dites moi tous ces colliers là c'est
pour moi je suis désolé mon pôvre maïmir
effectivement aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup
de colis j'ai dû me faire aider tu vois
avant mais je n'ai rien pour toi c'est
dommage j'adore ouvrir et colis parce
que donc tout ce gros paquet il n'y en a
pas un seul pour moi et non 90 août et
pour julie et mon frère alors ce n'est
pas juste un ce n'est pas juste
il est parti bouder ce alors c'est
pourtant pas sur l'habitude mais vous
comprenez il est tellement déçu parce
qu'il adore recevoir des colis
heureusement qu'avec liste n'est jamais
bien grave dites-moi julie où je voulais
posent tous ces colis des dans le
kiosque ouhlala nous nommons qui
abondent à faire sur ces bons à bon
alors sur le banc tanaisie des enfants
mais tu es là bas ça fait que ça
commençait à faire le un didon c'est
formidable de recevoir comme ça plaide
collégiens j'ai vu qu'il emmenait de
tous les pays pour vous les attendiez
bien sûr c'est moi qu'il fait les
commandes
c'est pour avoir une collection complète
de poupées du monde entier a montré aux
enfants ça alors j'ai dit on peut dire
que vous avez des idées formidables
c'est vrai rien que de voir les noms de
tous ces pays
pas moi moi ça m'impressionne 1 et
pourtant je suis de la partie 1 est
facteur ce que vous connaissez le nom de
chaque pays tels que l'écrivent ses
habitants je dois t'avouer que non et on
va voir si les enfants sont plus avec
vous ap les enfants
regardez j'ai fait une commande pour
avoir une collection de poupées du monde
entier sur chaque colis il ya une
éthique at oui marque et le nom du pays
telles que l'écrivent ses habitants
est-ce que vous avez les reconnaître par
exemple regarder nederland d'après vous
quel pays c'est la hollande oui c'est ça
il ya le pays bas exactement ni d'heure
sebha landes cpi voilà helvetia sérique
suisse la suisse c'est énorme je crois
que ton relance mais ça va vite la
bulgarie ya r ça fait pas très bien
valérie et c'est plus précisément
l'irlande du sud
cette longue date locaux alors polska
bien marri la pologne
ah ça c'est très compliqué cccp les
richesses
j'ai très bien eric comment tu sais ça
l'écriture en russe le ccs en fait et le
pcr voilà il faut savoir tout à fait
ridge je crois que c'est comme ça que ça
se prononce suis passé pro chez bras non
catherine elle marie s'est pas philippe
sella suède
je crois qu'il est assez simple corps
restera non nantis strike nathalie non
elsa restera ch
c'est un peu la même consonance en
france est pas tout à fait il est oui
l'autriche fait venir quatre jeunes bon
je crois que c'est tout un facteur
oui on sait tous et tous avait il est
bon et bien c'est très bien les enfants
vous pouvez retourner jouer avant le
facteur vous savez mademoiselle julie
j'ai appris plein de choses aujourd'hui
bien je vous remercie bien elle se sent
pris facteurs bon allez et bonne
continuation pour manger dit enfin c'est
julie
ah tiens tu as fini de bouder je ne
voulais pas mais je trouve que ce n'est
pas juste que tu es tous les paquets
pour toi et j'aimerais en avoir un mais
coûte c'est une commande que j'ai fait
pour avoir des poupées du monde entier
oh oui bon alors c'est toujours pareil
moi je ne reçois jamais ni un paquet
noulette et pourtant ma plus grande joie
c'est d'ouvrir des paquets tu veut en
ouvrir un howie lequel choisi celui-là
le plus petit mais non justement celui
là non parce que bon alors c'est ça
qu'ils ont tout de suite tu veux pas que
j'ouvre ce paquet et que je simplement
de prévenir ou c'est ça que je suis pas
capable de l'ouvrir moi même et que tu
préfères l'ouvrir toi donc c'est
toujours pareil
et bien tant pis une voix le bon le
diable à aa
casimir
[Musique]